hey everyone welcome back to css3 in 30
days or code 30 things and 30 games at
css3 whatever you want to call it today
we're going to be playing with the CSS
clip path property which allows us to
make custom shapes from an image so
we'll put an HTML image in our markup
and then you can clip a path around a
shape to create circles polygons
triangles custom shapes it's pretty cool
and plus I'm going to show you a neat
online free tool that lets you kind of
draw your own shape and then copy the
CSS I mean that's cool so head over here
into my screen and this is what we're
gonna be doing here so day 3 is clipping
images the course files as usual in
every module there's going to be a
dedicated lesson there that's going to
allow you to download the course files
for each day so today is three clipping
images you're gonna get index final and
sandbox dot CSS of course the sandbox is
where we're gonna add our CSS and final
is where you can reference the final CSS
for your own reference and for help and
the index is just the markup that's
already pre coded you're always welcome
to play around with it and do whatever
you want with it
but here's what we're gonna do so over
here in my browser day 3 clipping images
with shapes we're gonna use css3 to clip
the following images with different
shapes so I just have different images
stock images that I pulled from unsplash
that are just for random images at 300
by 300 pixels now here is the final
result first one is a circle second one
is a cool chat bubble a third one is an
X and number four is a right pointing
arrow and the cool thing here is these
are actual images that they're kind of
masked now they're not necessarily
masked because that's a separate thing
but clipped images is the property that
were going to be using and so if I just
drag on this image it's actually the
original square image but it's clipped
with this this circle and this one is
the chap the chat bubble
and this is the ex right facing arrow so
it's using exclusively CSS to get this
effect we don't have to use Photoshop so
this is pretty cool and it's actually
quite easy to to do and understand so
let's head over into our code editor and
into sandbox at CSS now the first thing
we want to do is we want to select this
first image example number one so that
image the class is we have it set up
here it's simply clip image one clip
image one and all we need to do is use a
simple property called clip - path and
then we're going to add the values but I
also want to be just a little bit more
safe here and do the prefix for WebKit
so let's start with WebKit clip path and
then we'll work our way down so we're
gonna start with just a circle so here's
the value that you add circle and then
parentheses and in there it's going to
accept some values so for a circle this
is what we write and then let's play
around with it so you can see how it
works so 50% at 50% 50% save that now if
I go over here to the browser you could
see it made the circle where we did it
now what happens when we change those
values what do these mean so if I were
to go like over here in the code editor
10% at 50% 50% that image that clip is
much smaller so technically the smaller
that first value the smaller the size of
the clip for the circle what if I were
to do 100% in the code editor here let's
see what happened nothing so perhaps
that size is just too large and 50% is
the maximum so if I were to do like 60%
perhaps you wouldn't even see it so that
60% is still being grabbed around the
corner so you can you know kind of
create this weird effect but 50%
effectively is going to make it all the
way around within the constraints of the
square image now you can play around
with that to see you at different
effects you can get now at 50 and 50
let's see what happens when I change
this first value to 10% and 50 head back
to the browser here
you could see this is the offset kind of
the offset of where the circle clip is
going to be positioned so 10% it looks
like it's about 10% to the left so maybe
what if I were to do zero let's just see
what that does
it goes straight down the center of the
circle now if I were to do 0% on the
other value it pushes that up so it's
going to the center so this is coming
from the center is what I'm gathering
from experimenting with this so zero and
zero is the center axis of the circle
and it's positioned at the top left so
it's taking the circle here's the circle
here we go and it's going from the
center and if I were to go 0 0 it's
going up into the top left for you maybe
it's up here of that square so the 0 and
0 axes of the square is going it's going
up here so we're only seeing a quadrant
of the circle now if you play around
with that some more you can see the
different results that you get you can
position that circle but 50 and 50 is
what gets you that circle clipped
perfectly over that image so that is the
first one right there now I'm going to
add clip path as well to be browser
compliant circle 50% at 50% 50% save
that now let me show you a cool trick if
you head to your browser and go to
Bennet feely comm slash Clippy he has
this really awesome CSS clip path maker
that lets you create clip paths and
there's demos and there's examples and
you just copy the CSS down here what's
cool about this is one if you just
wanted to quickly create a shape without
trying to figure it out yourself you
could do it here by using the presets
like triangles parallelograms rhombus
and so on or you can custom polygons and
create your own so let me let's just
play around with a couple here and and
do that so I'm going to show you up here
in our final example number two is this
chat message box so let's go down to
clip path maker
and find that message box cuz I got it
from here so down here message if I
click on this it gives me the clip path
down here that I could just copy paste
on to the next clip path image that we
have in our in our CSS and then we'd be
done with it but let's just see how it's
how it is made so you can see here it
has all these corners and this is how
it's creating the shape of the of the
actual message box and maybe let's
choose a more simple one just so you can
get the idea here triangle there's only
three values and we could see it down
here 50% and zero what happens if I
dragged this first value over to the far
left top left 0 and 0 what's the value
it's 0 and 0 even if I just moved it a
little bit 1% and 0 so clearly this top
one this top value is the x-axis so I'm
31 percent over 63 percent or 100
percent over so that's how you position
that first item at first point on the
clip and then if I were to go down you
can see the y-axis changes so that's how
that first point works and you can see
here point number 2
was this one if I drag it anywhere you
could see zero and zero is top left 150
and zero is top right
oh sorry 100 and zero I looked at that
wrong and anywhere else in the container
you can see the values change so the
triangle we're going down to the bottom
left at 100% so zero on the x-axis 100%
on the y-axis and then over here we have
100 and 100 because we're at the far
bottom right which is 100% down in the
over in the x-axis 100% down on the
y-axis so you get a triangle and so now
if I go back to the message I get a
number of different values and you could
just easily see where they're positioned
and how that works so that's pretty cool
so let's copy that and see what happens
I'm gonna copy that CSS go back to our
sandbox and I'm gonna select clip - path
- - and just paste those values now save
it and let's see what happened sorry
clip a clip image clip image - there we
go
now go to your browser and there we go
now you can see here in our first
example we use circle and in our second
example we used polygon circle has a
different set of values so as we played
around with just a couple minutes ago
and polygon goes based on however many
numeric values you have you have x and y
by comma and the more separated by comma
values you have the more points in your
your polygon you have and you can create
totally custom shapes so let's call that
clip image number two and we copied and
pasted it there let's go around and play
with this next one example number three
so this is an X so let's go to clip
image don't make a mistake again three
and let's start out with our clip path
clip - path and it's a polygon so we're
gonna do polygon and this is how I like
to do it to write them up he's just
literally a bit easier to read so
polygons and the parentheses semi-colon
and then write your first value I'm
gonna hit us return and then tab myself
in a little bit here just easier to read
this so I'm gonna start with 20% over
and zero on the y-axis so a little bit
over not down comma return let's go zero
percent and the next value will be
twenty percent now if I were to stop
there let's see what happens let's see
what that looks like it might be kind of
weird or you might not even see anything
so you don't see anything yet so let's
add a little bit more and see what we
can come up with the next one is 30% and
50% now I'm not just pulling these
numbers out of my butt here that this
was practiced and played around with
before using the clip path maker and
everything like that so so to create
something from scratch you'd have to
kind of map it out or use the clip path
maker but I want to show you how it
works in practice so let's add another
couple values here and see what we
create we're next we're gonna go zero on
the X and 80% on the Y now let's stop
there and let's see if anything's been
created yet so nothing yet
it's possible that maybe I'm typing
something incorrectly okay so the issue
here why I don't see it is because the
clip path property isn't rendering
properly in my browser my Atem built-in
browser so that's why we must be using
the WebKit clip path prefix at least for
me I need to use that so I'm gonna be
using that to start with so WebKit clip
path with our values let's see what
we've got so far there we go so you can
see it's creating value one two three
four there we go
so cool let's keep going so now the next
one's gonna be 20% and 100% the next one
be 50% on the X 70 percent on the Y 80
percent on the X is the next set of
values and 100 percent on the Y save
that let's see what we're coming up with
see fish taking shape you can see that
it's actually starting to take shape
so here in the values if we got 20
percent in 0 0 and 20 30 and 50 0 and 80
20 and 100 50 and 70 80 and 100 so we
just have a few more to create the rest
of this shape so let's go back to our
code editor we got 100 percent and then
80 and then we got 70 percent and 50
percent 100 percent and 20 percent save
it check it out again I just like seeing
this progress so you got you can see we
just have a little bit more to do we
just have too few more points back to
our code editor we got 80 percent and 20
percent and then we have 50 percent and
30 percent so you can see these kind of
start to mirror mirror things a little
bit so 20 and 100 we have 120 0 and 80
80 and a little bit different so some of
these values are in versts some of them
aren't so save that it should be our X
let's go back over to example number 3
no not quite so I did mess something up
here so go back to the code editor yes
right here so it's 80 and 0% and then 50
and 30 go back over here there we go
so I was right initially in my code
editor so it's you could see how these
are actually
so 50 30 80 0 120 we got zero let me see
so 30 50 0 80 28 100 so these are kind
of mirrored opposites so that is the web
could clip path copy that paste it below
and change the property simply to clip
path as the fallback that'll do the
trick
save that and there's your clip path
image 3 now finally the last one we have
is the right-facing arrow now feel free
to try creating it yourself
or you can go to the clip path maker and
draw your own version or you know if you
really wanted to you could just click
the right arrow it'll give you the
values like this and you can copy and
paste it or you can play around with
this drag it around you know create a
custom shape like so you know I just
created this like funky looking arrow
something like that but a little bit
funky copy that
head back over to your sandbox and I'm
gonna say clip image for paste that in
there save check it out in the final
result and we got my cool custom a weird
looking arrow there now what you can
also do is head over to the clip clip
path maker and click on custom polygons
and then just click to add some points
you know I'm just gonna go like this and
then you can click on that in the
checkbox and the top left here on your
first point and drag them around to
create a totally custom polygon shape
that you can use in your there you go I
kind of have like this hourglass
sideways Stanley Cup you know and then
there's your values and then feel free
to just try coding them out yourself so
those are the four examples we got our
circle then different sets of polygons
heavily using the Bennet feedly Clippy
path maker which is really cool thanks
Ben Ofili check it check a site out
follow him on Twitter do all the things
because he's made a really great tool
that makes our lives easier as web
designers and web developers and those
are your examples feel free to play
around with them make custom shapes and
use them in your own projects thanks for
watching day 3 clipping images with
shapes in css3 and 30 days Cheers
[Music]